canada imposed more sanctions today
targeting members of the russian elite
and major banks with me from ottawa is
canada's foreign affairs minister
melanie jolie madame minister let me ask
you about those sanctions you know the
ukrainian foreign minister has made it
very clear what he thinks needs to
happen he tweeted today i will not be
diplomatic on this everyone who now
doubts whether russia should be banned
from swift which is the international
banking system has to understand that
the blood of innocent ukrainian men
women and children will be on their
hands to
ban russia from swift he is unequivocal
why is that not happening right now
well you know we've said that there
would be extremely strong sanctions
that's what we announced today and we're
doing so at the same time as all our g7
allies so the us the uk the eu and japan
but we've also said and i've also said
donna that we would be adding sanctions
we had already
restricted actually limited completely
the sovereign debt of russia so the
capacity of russia to finance itself in
our
within our economy
and we had already
said that we would be making a dealing
ban between canada and the two regions
at the beginning of the week that had
been recognized as independence which is
don esquien and luhangs by the putin and
this recognition is completely outraging
what we're doing today is even
more
all the major banks of russia are now
under sanction
we are making sure also that
more than 60 individuals and entities
are sanctioned
by uh by canada i understand the
sanctions announced today are more
severe than they've ever been but why
hold back others why not sanction putin
himself why not ban russia from swift
well like i mentioned
we will continue to impose sanctions
we will make sure that we're acting in a
coordinated way
we very much know also that canada
doesn't have a huge amount of trade with
russia because of our geography but
because also we had sanctioned
years ago when russia invaded crimea 400
individuals and entities
what we want to do though is to make
sure that there's no loophole
in this sanctioned approach
can you see a point where canadian
soldiers would be on the ground in
eastern europe fighting russian forces
well we've decided to reinforce
our participation
within nato and
should article five so should a threat
to use of force against a member of the
alliance uh be be done by russia well of
course we will make sure to uh react and
promptly that's why i had the chance to
be in contact with secretary general of
nato ian stoltenberg earlier today
because obviously what is at stake right
now is europe's security and when
europe's security is at stake it is also
our own security that is at stake
minister jolie thanks for taking time
with us
thank you thank you donna thank you
mercedes stevenson is with me now from
ottawa mercedes canada and other
countries holding back being as tough as
they could be with sanctions are they
keeping their powder dry what are we and
our allies waiting for i think a lot of
people are wondering that as we see what
looks like a full-scale invasion in
ukraine people are wondering why not act
now there's a few reasons that may be
going into this calculation the first is
political will of our allies
essentially the g7 nato countries want
to act in lockstep because it's more
powerful but some of those countries
could face significant economic
consequences for action taken including
canada there's also the desire right now
to leave an exit route for vladimir
putin to perhaps fall back and not try
to hold all of ukraine and concerns that
targeting him in particular could lead
to a bit of a trumpian response where if
he's challenged he becomes more
aggressive personally but i did ask
prime minister justin trudeau if
sanctioning vladimir putin is on his
radar this is what he said today
the key thing on sanctions has been
to come forward in a coordinated way
with all our allies and that is the
unity that is uh most damaging
uh to the kremlin
and to vladimir putin that we are all
unequivocal and united on this
so it sounds like it's potentially on
the table there are more sanctions
coming but they need the buy-in
obviously of all the allies in order to
do that in the meantime there are other
things that can be done as well
including banning russian oil and gas
from canada it is imported here the
prime minister would not commit to that
today and of course the ukrainians are
asking for things they are asking for
things including weapons and support
take a listen to what the ukrainian
charges affairs told me
they need helmets they need tactical
armored jackets they need firearms they
are ready to fight but they need
ammunition they need
equipment and then they need arms yes
indeed we need more
so donna whether or not canada decides
to provide more lethal aid remains to be
seen
okay mercedes thanks